the last time
the last time I went on stage on
mushrooms at the coffee store about two
minutes before the set I was like I
gotta poop so bad oh no it's the worst I
was like
he was like hurry I go hurry hurry and
so I go poop and I and I run out on
stage and I'm laughing having a good
time and the next day I fly straight
from LA to Orlando for a show
and I take my jeans that I was wearing
that night at The Comedy Store out of my
bag and guys there was [__]
this way
a horizontal outside of my pants this
way horizontally
above my [__] yeah
and I hold up the pants and Beth goes
what is it I go I think it's [__]
why do you have [__] on the outside of
your pants horizontal I'm like I don't
know your one leg went out of your pant
leg and you went to pick them up and
that's the only way we went